merde
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur public sénat dans un
instant vous allez pouvoir suivre
l'audition de valérie fourneyron
la ministre des sports est entendu par
la commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur
l'efficacité de la lutte contre le
dopage
récemment la ministre s'est déclarée
opposée à une pénalisation de l' usage
de produits dopants alors pour en savoir
plus direction la salle clémenceau bonne
après midi à tous pour l'instant ils
vont revenir
il s'agissait principalement d'amis de
la presse d'autres vont les remplacer où
ils les mêmes vont revenir et ils sont
sans doute en train de demander des
vérifications complémentaires aux
personnes que nous avons reçue à voir
vous mali ce que je peux vous proposer
c'est de faire propos liminaire
d'environ un quart d'heure 30 minutes m
e minute c'est vous qui jurait la
longueur sur ce que vous pensez de la
lutte contre le dopage et ensuite les
membres de cette commission d' enquête a
commencé dans le rapporteur auront sans
doute des questions complémentaires à
vous poser bon c'est une méthode très
simple nous écoutons de la lys
merci ce président sera porteur sur les
sénateurs permettez moi effectivement de
d'ouvrir ce moment d'audition par un
propos introductif fait essayer le plus
brièvement possible lilian sont des
facettes du dopage sont tout de même
importante a essayé de les aborder avec
vous cet après midi car bien sûr la
ministre des sports de la jeunesse
éducation populaire et de la vie
associative qui est là celle qui est
responsable pour le gouvernement dans
notre organisation de la lutte contre le
dopage en france et de l'efficacité de
cette lutte contre le dopage mais envie
de vous dire que et de vous expliquer
pourquoi ce sujet de la lutte contre le
dopage pour moi un sujet extrêmement
important peut-être très structurant
finalement dans mon parcours
professionnel est aujourd'hui du coup
qui explique mon engagement puisque
c'est un an 87 n'a pas me rajeunir t
médecin inspecteur régional jeunesse et
des sports et que j'ai eu dans cette
fonction à coordonner tout début la
lutte contre le dopage l'organisation
des contrôles et même pour tout vous
dire la dernière fois et la seule fois
où j'ai prêté serment
c'est aujourd'hui la deuxième c'était
comme médecin contrôleur et en 80 ans 89
quand j'ai eu a ensuite a dirigé la
mission de médecine du sport la
politique était assez loin de mon
univers cette époque celui a dirigé le
bureau de médecine du sport du ministère
des sports qui est un secrétariat d'état
à l'époque et 7 à cette occasion que
j'ai eue a contribué à la rédaction de
la loi dopage de 89 dont il faut se
souvenir peut-être que c'est le moment
où le on sort le sportifs dopés de la
juridiction pénale concerne à ce moment
là les seules trafic en jugeant que la
temporalité juridique n'était pas adopté
adapté à la temporalité sportive c'est
ce moment on se fait confiance au
mouvement sportif et à ses règlements
disciplinaires donc dans la
responsabilité de sanctionner les
contrevenants et sa affirme à cette
occasion le rôle de l'état pour la
première fois dans la protection de la
santé des sportifs étaient quelques
fonctions à deux médecins du sport dans
différentes équipes et c'était pour moi
absolument nécessaire ensuite il ya
toujours de ses responsabilités
professionnelles
j'étais amené après l' affaire festina
donc en 98 à participer au groupe
interministériel qui avait mis en place
marie george buffet et bernard kouchner
qui était sur la présidence du
professeur et secondes et nous avions
dans ce cadre la fait évoluer aussi le
dispositif législatif et participer à la
dynamique internationale de mise en
place de l'agencé mondiale antidopage
suis devenu en janvier vous le savez la
représentante du continent européen
au sein du comité exécutif de l'agencé
mondiale antidopage par ces éléments
question de bien de faire une quelconque
valorisation d'un parcours personnel
mais bien de vous dire que c'est au
coeur des préoccupations que j'ai comme
médecin que j'ai produites et contre à
la fois à dire l'éthique du sport et
protéger la santé des sportifs et je
voudrais vous remercier vous remercier
d'avoir pris cette initiative d'avoir
pris cette initiative est de la qualité
du travail que vous avez pu effectuer à
l'occasion des ja de ses auditions et
des déplacements qui je le sais ont
permis d'alimenter votre votre réflexion
collective et votre commission denquête
l'usada permis en 2012 de montrer aux
yeux du monde entier que celui qui se
prétendait être le plus grand des
champions était en réalité le plus grand
des tricheurs amené à dire un plusieurs
reprises que nous devions pas laisser
passer cette affaire amstrong comme une
affaire de plus dans la lutte contre le
dopage s'ajoutent en effectivement à la
liste d affaire festina ou faire tôt
il doit pour ou y avoir un avant et un
après et c'est de notre responsabilité à
tous et le sénat s'est pleinement saisir
de ce sujet au sein de votre commission
commission qui a permis d'entendre en
beauce personnes sur ce sujet avec des
sentiments sans doute différent anto de
l'engagement du volontarisme tantôt un
peu du fatalisme ou de la résignation à
ce que j'en ai lu tantôt un peu du repli
sur soi mais nous avons appris et été
croît étonné sont des auditions que j'ai
pu lire la foi de témoignages de
certains qui ne veulent pas voir ou
savoir ce qui se passe
d'autres qui remettent en cause les
principes mêmes de la lutte contre le
dopage qui pense presque que le dopage
n'est pas un problème dans le sport nous
avons été émus aussi par les aveux de
certains les explication du pourquoi des
pratiques le décès tragique de philippe
gaumont la veille de son audition
également aujourd'hui témoigner devant
la représentation nationale devant dire
votre commission denquête de l'action de
mon ministère et des principes qui la
guide
une action qui s'est inscrite dans la
continuité des différents gouvernements
nous faut il me semble répondre dans un
premier temps vu ensemble des l'ambiance
générale de cette commission d' enquête
et des auditions que vous avez fait à un
élément qui finalement plus simple
pourquoi lutter contre le dopage
préserver l'éthique du sport protéger la
santé des sportifs sont les deux
éléments de réponse la première est
évidente préserver l'esprit du sport
l'éthique du sport et sans rentrer dans
un exercice toujours compliqué de la
définition me semble que le sport est
caractérisée par deux choses l'égalité
des chances et l'incertitude du résultat
le dopage remet fondamentalement en
cause cette égalité des chances
d'aucuns diront que les conditions
d'entraînement les différences physiques
entrave déjà cette notion d'égalité mais
ce site
n'a rien à voir si parfois les
techniques d'entraînement jean plus
sophistiqué de récupération cela ne
modifie pas fondamentalement le profil
physiologique d'un sportif et le dopage
ci modifie les critères sanguin modifie
la puissance musculaire plus que
n'importe quel programme de musculation
pour elle permettre permet de décupler
aussi la puissance développée comme le
monde certaines études encore les plus
récentes sur le cyclisme sur ces nombre
de watts calculé développer et azuréens
des étapes ça qu'il existe une liste de
produits interdits c'est pour ça que les
sportifs ne peuvent pas prendre toutes
ces substances et utiliser toutes les
techniques
cette liste tranquille est bon de le
rappeler
elle est établie à partir de critères
avec trois critères déterminants
amélioration de la performance danger
pour la santé des sportifs contradiction
avec l'esprit du sport si deux de ces
critères sont remplis alors le produit
est interdite critères sont justes car
il inclut la performance l'esprit du
sport et la protection de la santé des
sportifs
il a longuement été évoquée dans les
dernières discussions j'y reviendrai sur
la révision du code mondial antidopage
qu'elle j'ai pris part a donc récemment
sur la possibilité de rendre obligatoire
le premier critère à dire l'augmentation
de la performance
nous avons obtenu finalement qu'il ne
change pas et il s'agit d'une bonne
nouvelle car il était essentiel pour
nous que reste sur le même plan les
critères de la performance et les
critères de la santé des sportifs car
nous c'est bien la deuxième partie de
cette réponse à pourquoi lutter contre
le dopage
préserver la santé des sportifs et là
encore j'ai entendu lu vu que nous ne
connaissions pas finalement les risques
du dopage pour la santé des sportifs
quelques discours qui banaliserait des
pratiques dangereuses médecins comme
ministre oui le dopage est dangereux
et les pratiques dopantes font courir un
risque majeur à nos athlètes
je ne vous prendrai pas l'ensemble des
effets secondaires pourraient le faire
longuement des stéroïdes des stimulants
de le pays
mais combien on a pu malheureusement
découvrir par des premiers accidents
d'obstruction vasculaire de thrombose le
risque d'augmentation de la viscosité du
sort et de l'utilisation de l'eau p o
et on l'a vue venir parce que ce sont
les sportifs qui ont servi de cobayes
combien vous même peut-être quand vous
êtes amené à prendre des corticoïdes sur
une sinusite et bien pu constater qu'il
valait mieux les prendre le matin que le
soir tellement il y avait je veux dire
un sentiment de l'excitation de
repousser un peu ses limites
et encore on a aujourd'hui une réalité
une réalité scientifique mais réalité
scientifique largement validé les études
sont nombreuses celles de 2006 celle de
spider qui est très intéressante sur
l'ensemble de ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne dans un autre temps sur les
conséquences sur toute une population de
jeunes sportifs
on a cette dernière étude qui est celle
sur les footballeurs italiens qui sept à
huit fois plus ce n'est pas de chance de
malchance d'avoir une sclérose latérale
amyotrophique deux fois plus de cancers
sur une population de 24 mille sportifs
qui a été étudiée alors oui lutter
contre le dopage c'est lutter pour
l'éthique du sport la sincérité du
résultat mais aussi la protection des
sportifs et le rôle du ministère c'est
bien sûr d'abord de faire respecter
l'arsenal législatif qui existe est de
contribuer avec l'aide du parlement à
l'améliorer en permanence depuis la loi
herzog
dès le 1er juin 65 a fait de la france
le premier grand pays européen à se
doter d'une législation réprimant le
dopage jusqu'à la promulgation de
l'ordonnancé du 14 avril 2010 la lutte
contre le dopage est motivée par
cette promotion et cette défense de
l'éthique et cette défense de la santé
des sportifs objectif de se conformer
aux conventions internationales de lutte
contre le dopage auquel la france a
adhéré celle du conseil de l'europe de
89 celle de l'unesco 2005 qui comporte
en appendice le code mondial antidopage
vertu de la loi de 65 le fait de s'être
dopé sylla était intentionnel constitue
un délai sanctionner pénalement
ensuite c'est la loi mon but de 89
je les dis elle le fait de se doper ne
relève plus du pénal en revanche la
pénalisation de ce qu'on peut déjà
appeler le trafic des produits dopants
peut conduire jusqu'à dix ans
d'emprisonnement
en 99 c'est la loi buffet qui vise à la
fois la prévention le renforcement de la
protection de la santé des sportifs
la mise en oeuvre d'un suivi médical
longitudinale tout en prévoyant donc une
lutte renforcée contre les pourvoyeurs
en 2006 c'est la loi lamour qui réalise
la première transcription en droit
français du code mondial antidopage de
2003 et un texte qui ressentent les
missions du ministère vers la prévention
la protection du public la promotion de
la santé et la recherche dans ses textes
il y as nilan étant la détention ni les
autres activités caractérisant un trafic
à conséquent à ce moment là les services
de police judiciaire ne disposez pas
d'instruments juridiques leur permettant
de faire face à la réalité des modes
opératoires des trafiquants en 2008 la
loi laporte met à jour le droit français
avec le droit international et la
convention internationale contre le
dopage dans le sport sous l'égide de
l'unesco adoptée en 2005 impose aux
états parties dans son article 8 de
limiter la disponibilité l'utilisation
dans le sport des substances dopantes
lutter contre le trafic en limitant la
production la circulation l'importation
la distribution et la vente de ces
substances et procéder aux sportifs le
nouveau code mondial est adoptée à
madrid en novembre 2007 fait également
une exigence forte de l'ensemble de
cette lutte sur les trafics
ces dispositions elles ont conduit la
france à créer une nouvelle infraction
l'infraction pénale de détention des
produits dopants permettant aux
enquêteurs d'engager les procédures
visant remontée et démanteler les
filières de distribution
le panel des incriminations pénales
existantes en matière de trafic et donc
complété et tous ces textes sont
désormais intégrées dans le code du
sport au titre iii donc santé les
sportifs et lutte contre le dopage c'est
la préservation de la santé qui outre la
lutte contre la tricherie a toujours
conditionné la position du ministère des
sports en cohérence avec celle du
mouvement sportif sur le sujet sur ce
registre
ma conviction sur ce débat sur la
pénalisation de l'usagé des produits
dopants par l'utilisateur qui posent
plusieurs difficultés
ma conviction est claire je dirais même
ferme
je suis opposé à la pénalisation de
l'usaj j'ai eu l'occasion de l'expliquer
il ya plusieurs mois
il me semble que deux concerts là encore
dans ce travail depuis plusieurs années
avec le mouvement sportif
je suis convaincu que le sportif doit
être protégée et non condamnés que le
problème du dopage est un enjeu de santé
publique
avant d'être un enjeu pénale da sportif
se dope pour gagner se met en danger
ils jouent les cobayes humains étant des
produits dont les effets à terme sont
inconnues scientifiques ne peuvent pas
ne doivent pas conduire des études ou
éventuellement sur les rats de
laboratoire en utilisant des doses
énormes sur des patients qui ne sont pas
malades et donc la base scientifique
malheureusement est souvent le sportif
qui lui même se retrouve dans une
situation d'être le cobaye qui n'a pas
pu être celui d'études scientifiques du
fait qu'une détournement de
l'utilisation du produit et de sa dose
et donc
quant à sportif se dopent il se met en
danger c'est aussi sous cet aspect qu'il
faut considérer le croit la lutte contre
le dopage condamné pénalement les
tricheurs c'est se mettre en position de
défiance envers les sportifs en position
de défiance envers les fédérations le
rôle du ministère des sports il me
semble les pins de créer un climat
pénale autour du sport mais bien de
protéger les sportifs et donc de
protéger le sport c'est cette conviction
qui l'imaginé non n'enlève rien à ma
détermination de lutter contre le dopage
serait pas complète sur la législation
si je n'évoquais pas surtout avec vous
la loi du 12 mars 2012 qui grâce au
travail du sénat aux amendements que
vous aviez déposé met en place le profil
biologique pour certains paramètres des
sportifs et en réserve son usage certain
nombre de sportifs de haut niveau
ces sportifs étant parallèlement
assujettis aux dispositifs de
géolocalisation
le passeport biologique de l'athlète il
est aussi un outil développé par l'
agence mondiale antidopage
sa généralisation fait partie des
recommandations
aujourd'hui du rapport pound consiste
donc en la révision de ces séries
d'examens biologiques base de paramètres
avec des règles opérationnelle
rigoureuse et donc un d'examen qui sont
consignées dans un document passeport
biologique de l'athlète que des experts
ensuite vont évaluer et value sur la
durée et donc c'est une nouvelle
approche de preuves non analytiques et
de protection de la santé des sportifs
sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres la
france reste en pointe et un comité de
préfiguration même si je sais ce qu'on
aimerait que ça avance plus vite mais un
comité de préfiguration est en cours
présidée par l' agence française de
lutte contre le dopage
s'il doit se réunir une dernière fois en
juin prochain avant de finaliser ensuite
le rapport qui aboutira donc ça sous
comité d'experts un décret en conseil
d'état
bref ces dispositions sur le passeport
biologique elles ont vocation 1
devenir universel et à être discuté dans
ce cadre plus large du code mondial
antidopage donc l'arsenal législatif il
est important en perpétuelle évolution
parlement à jouer pleinement son rôle à
chacune de ses étapes et les textes
continueront à s'enrichir à commencer
par les propositions qui je le sais ne
manqueront pas de sortir de votre
commission denquête le rôle du ministère
ne se limite pas au texte à leurs
applications et la direction des sports
travaille aussi activement sur
l'ensemble des volets de la lutte contre
le dopage
les volets de prévention des volets
d'organisation collective avec ce plan
de prévention 2013-2016 que nous avons
arrêté un volet grand public d'abord
avec l'association du ministère de la
direction des sports aux travaux du
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel pour
la diffusion de programmes concernant la
lutte contre le dopage avec des kits de
communication qui sont à disposition du
csa avec un élargissement de la
possibilité de les voir sur les écrans
avec aussi la sensibilisation des
usagers des clubs de remise en forme
porté par l'implication avec ce
ministère la fédération française
d'haltérophilie on utilise en ce moment
la possibilité de pouvoir exercer des
contrôles d'engager des enquêtes dans
les salles de remise en forme du secteur
commercial
sachant que ces salles doivent être en
conformité avec la réglementation sur
leur encadrement en termes
d'établissement d'encadrement
d'activités sportives la mise en place
aussi du numéro vert et écoute dopage
porte est donc par dopage info service
en termes de chiffres été chercher les
chiffres on est en moyenne 1 338 appels
par mois
iron 240 courriel par mois la création
vous le savez des antennes médicales de
prévention du dopage moyenne pour
l'ensemble des antennes médicales 1000
consultations par an ce fait à peu près
42 par antenne
et elle bénéficie en termes de
financement de la part territoriale du
centre national de développement du
sport mis aussi à disposition d'outils
de sensibilisation travail conjoint avec
la mildt le deuxième ça c'est le grand
public le deuxième axe indispensable et
celui à destination du mouvement sportif
donc soutien financier aussi des
fédérations qui s'engage dans des
programmes de prévention du dopage et
sur ce chapitre en dépit de quelques
contraintes budgétaires qui n'ont
échappé à personne
les moyens des fédérations pour la lutte
antidopage ont été entièrement préservée
sur le budget 2013 soutenir également
les territoires par le biais des projets
de clubs qui intègre des projets de
sensibilisation de leurs adhérents
enfin nous avons défini en juillet
dernier une norme qualité afnor qui
garantit aux sportifs l'assurance de la
qualité des compléments alimentaires
lorsqu'il a donc cette norme afnor donc
les actions de travail de la direction
des sports sont nombreuses elles doivent
être je le sais sans cesse améliorés et
approfondie ministère des sports est
enfin le financeur majeur principal de
l'acteur majeur de la lutte contre le
dopage de la puissance publique qui est
bien sûr l' agence française de lutte
contre le dopage autorité administrative
indépendante
je soulignais les avancées considérables
ont été faites ces dernières années et
qui ont permis comme lors du tour de
france 2008 de dépister les tricheurs
mais parce qu'il faut toujours être
attentif à à lire ces résultats positifs
une agence comme la fld ne peut
fonctionner correctement sans un secteur
des contrôles qui soit efficient et sans
une recherche de pointe et afin de
préserver la pertinence le caractère
inopiné des contrôles le secteur qui en
a la charge doit conformément à l'esprit
de la loi
jouir d'une totale indépendance pour
tous ces aspects techniques fonctionnels
moi c'est réaffirmer ici l'attachement
du gouvernement à ce principe essentiel
qui doit s'exercer dans le cadre du plan
stratégique annuelle du budget qui est
un parti à l'âge ans après adoption par
son collège vont sur ce sujet certes
nous féliciter de plus de 80% des
contrôles qui sont aujourd'hui inopinés
comme l'a précisé le président genevois
dans son rapport d'activité qui vient
d'être publié et pour accroître son
efficacité
convaincu que le secteur chargé des
contrôles doit pouvoir s'appuyer outre
sur une démarche d'investigation qui lui
est propre sur une collaboration étroite
avec la gendarmerie la police les
douanes sein de l' agence il doit
pouvoir collaborer avec le secteur en
ayant en charge l'instruction des
dossiers le secteur scientifique qui
notamment aura la mission d'assurer le
suivi du profil âge biologique
tout ce travail qui mérite d'être saluée
de tous les agents du ministère de tout
le personnel de l'agencé française de
lutte contre le dopage permettra je n'en
doute pas à la france de rester un pays
moteur mais là encore le savon ça ne
suffit pas et nous avons besoin de mieux
coordonner nos actions de se fédérer
autour de nos convictions et cela dépend
de nous
gouvernement le ministère du législateur
du mouvement sportif mais également de
l'international savons tous que dans
l'époque mondialisé dans lequel nous
vivons la lutte contre les trafics
contre les tricheurs se joue aussi au
delà de nos frontières et vous avez fait
de nombreux déplacements dans le cadre
de cette commission denquête sans nul
doute sur ce registre forte utile ce
sens l'un des rôles de mon ministère est
aussi d'assurer le rôle moteur de la
france
plusieurs instances incontournable dans
la lutte contre le dopage conseil de
l'europe
précurseur sur le sujet avec le texte de
89 unesco encore il ya quelques jours à
berlin à la convention de l'unesco
mintz conventions internationales de
adopté par plus de 170 pays
et là on va bien sûr qui a la
responsabilité de la lutte antidopage à
l'international et celle essentielle de
la rédaction du code mondial antidopage
qui s'impose à toutes les fédérations
internationales et que l'unesco impose
comme base juridique à tous les pays
signataires de la convention le travail
du conseil de l'europe
il consiste essentiellement dans deux
groupes fois le groupe de suivi de la
lutte contre le dopage dans la
principale mission est de veiller au
respect du traité par les états parties
le kama quel comité dit haddock européen
pour l' agence mondiale antidopage
comité d'experts qui est chargé de
coordonner la position de l'europe au
sein de l' agence mondiale antidopage
la france est évidemment représentée au
sein de ces groupes par la direction des
sports du ministère et le rôle du cama
est vraiment essentiel en amont des
comités exécutifs et plus ou là sur mon
ordre compte et des conseils de
fondation de l'ama
ce rôle moteur et fort que je vous le
conseil de l'europe pour fédérer les
pays européens entre la lutte contre le
dopage c'est l'unesco qui le joue à
l'international avec la conférence des
parties conférence statutaire qui a lieu
tous les deux ans pour examiner la mise
en oeuvre le suivi de la convention
internationale
une conférence elle nourrit plusieurs
objectifs dont celui de fournir une
plate forme d échanges et débats à ces
deux organes de coordination des états
au niveau européen au niveau mondial il
faut donc ajouter lama qui fait le lien
avec le mouvement sportif 50% de
représentants du monde sportif
50% des autorités publiques un
représentant par continent
c'est aujourd'hui une institution
centrale de la lutte contre le dopage
elle édicte les règles par le code pour
le code mondial
elle est aussi motrices sur la recherche
l'éducation la prévention c'est
l'institution centrale parce qu'elle
accrédite et des accrédite les
laboratoires parce qu'elles travaillent
en lien avec les pays
en retard ou avec ceux qui vont
accueillir des compétitions
internationales
me semble tant que membre du comité
exécutif indispensable d'évoquer avec
vous les deux sujets d'actualité
essentiel pour l'avenir la lutte contre
le dopage et pour la lutte
internationale
la révision du code et le rapport de
dick pound l'ancien président de l'ama
sur l'efficacité de la lutte contre le
dopage sur le travail sur né à la
version 10 3.0 du code mondial révisé je
vais évidemment pas vous faire une liste
de l'ensemble des articles qui
pourraient évoluer mais juste quelques
points qui me semble essentiel d'abord
celui concernant les sanctions
c'est sans doute une des modifications
les plus visibles du nouveau code
le passage de deux à quatre ans pour la
sanction en train quand un contrôle est
positif sur une substance dit lourde
cette position européenne également
défendu elle est me semble une bonne
nouvelle d'abord pour dire et rappeler
qu'on ne transige pas avec la lutte
contre le dopage mais nécessaire quand
on voit le nombre de récidivistes qui
après un ou deux ans de suspension
revienne et se font de nouveau prendre
concernant les pouvoirs d'investigation
lagence se voit confier la possibilité
de lancer ses propres enquêtes sur les
violations des règles antidopage
cela apparaît d'autant plus important
que toutes les leçons de l'affairé
armstrong n'ont pas été tirées et
l'initiative de la france
l'initiative de l'ensemble des pays
européens où paie ensuite avec les états
unis et tous les continents nous avons
signé une lettre commune demandant un
l'ensemble des autorités publiques de
soutenir la main sur ce rôle essentiel
de pouvoir avoir des com
si on enquête totalement indépendante
quand l'actualité le justifie sujet
importante autour du respect des droits
de la personne
art à voir ce principe aussi de la
proportionnalité de la sanction de
l'importance de la prévention et
d'éducation de nombreuses remarques de
nombreux amendements ont été pris en
compte sur ce respect des droits de
chacun
le code doit respecter effectivement un
certain nombre de droits
les exigences européennes en termes de
protection des données individuelles
droits de l'homme de l'égalité devant la
justice c'est aussi un sens que la
période pour comptabiliser les no show
les fameux trois no-shows sera réduite
de 18 à 12 mois en tous les cas dans la
version actuelle l'action n'est pas
encore définitivement arrêtée elle le
sera à johannesburg
à la fin de l'année ça dans le rôle des
acteurs renforcement du rôle des agences
nationales par rapport aux fédérations
internationales organisations nationales
antidopage auront la possibilité
automatique et non pas après avoir
demandé l'autorisation à la main
d'effectuer des contrôles additionnels
sur les compétitions internationales
organisées sur leur territoire dès lors
que la fédération internationale
la mandate pour prendre en charge des
contrôles le code pour être encore aller
plus loin en ce sens pour qu'andré de
carence des fédérations internationales
les agences nationales puissent
automatiquement prendre le relais semble
nous sommes très attentifs à ce sujet
car il est extrêmement difficile d'être
juge et partie
donc pas faire injure au mouvement
sportif mais bien au contraire de dire
que des instances neutre doivent pouvoir
être l'acteur principal des contrôles
serna enfin les décisions thérapeutiques
pour lutter contre le dopage
à noter que de nouvelles décisions ont
été prises concernant les fameuses à ut
autorisation à usage thérapeutique qui
pourront désormais de contester par les
agences nationales ou parler
organisateur de compétitions le maintien
sur un pied d'égalité
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure des trois
critères définissant les produits
dopants une inquiétude
ça permet de maintenir les corticoïdes
sur la liste des substances interdites
l'utilisation donc des données du
passeport biologique du suivi
longitudinal comme preuves de dopage a
été renforcée et dans le même temps les
seuils de détection pour le cannabis
seront relevés
c'est là aussi un nouvel satisfaisante
pour la lutte contre le dopage
car les traces de thc reste très
longtemps on le sait dans les urines et
de ce fait nous avions une avalanche de
contrôle positif du coup de procédures
en cours qui étaient le fait de dire
d'un usage qui était loin de la luz âge
pour la performance le jour de la
compétition et qui multipliait les
procédures de contrôle positif
c est donc sans intention d'utiliser un
produit pour améliorer la performance
l'autre sujet ressent majeur est le
rapport de dick pound sur l'inefficacité
de la lutte contre le dopage dans ce
rapport pourrait dire sans concession de
mai 2013 l'ancien président met en
exergue les difficultés les défauts
d'organisation de il interpelle tous les
acteurs de la lutte contre le dopage et
dresse un certain nombre de
recommandations
tout le monde est mis face à ses
responsabilités sans tabou rapport
propose la possibilité pour les au nahd
donc les agences de contrôle et les
sportifs étrangers sur son territoire
plus d'obligation d'échangé
d'informations avec les fédérations
internationales
l'obligation de conformité au code pour
tous les états et toutes les fédérations
plusieurs éléments autour de la
généralisation du passeport biologique
et l'indépendance des zones ac face à
tous pression extérieure
mais l'enjeu principal de ce rapport
sera surtout de ce pro
on sait se prononcer sur le
positionnement à l'avenir de l'ama sur
son rôle dans la lutte contre le dopage
pour certains l'agent ce doit être un
prestataire de service des fédérations
internationales et pour d'autres comme
les gouvernements les autorités
publiques doit être avant tout une
agence de régulation et de conformité au
code des différentes parties prenantes
prochain comité exécutif donc de l'ama
se déroulera le 11 septembre prochain
buenos aires aura une importance
capitale car nous aurons dans ce cadre
au sujet de la révision du code mais
surtout sur les suites du rapport
pendent à apporter notre contribution au
titre des autorités gouvernementales
personne donc ne se reposent si je peux
dire sur ses équipes tout le monde
permanence remet en cause se remet en
cause pour améliorer notre lutte contre
le dopage
ce volontarisme politique
nous en avons eu je crois une belle
illustration avec la nouvelle convention
c'est la première c'est la première fois
signé entre le cio et l'agencé française
de lutte contre le dopage pour le tour
de france 2013 car suite révélation de
l'affairé armstrong aux soupçons
légitimes qui ont pesé sur lui seyait
dont trévise taggart vous a fait part d'
avons travaillé avec l'agencé française
avec la ffc avec à etsaut sur les
conditions qui nous paraissait
nécessaire d'obtenir pour ce tour du
centenaire et je félicite l'agencé
française de lutte contre le dopage
d'avoir permis d'obtenir cette
convention avec lui c'est y est d'avoir
toutes les conditions requises de
disposer des résultats du suivi
biologique tome de disposer de la
localisation des coureurs avant le tour
pendant le tour et nous avons pu voir la
pertinence aussi de ces dispositifs
l'occasion du dauphiné contrôles seront
améliorées mais nous travaillons aussi
sur avec toutes les parties pour que le
dispositif de look la sève de la
gendarmerie des douanes soit plus
efficace que jamais et que les parquets
soit particulièrement impliqué avions
également sur le décret élargissant la
liste des agents habilités à rechercher
les a constaté les trafics de produits
dopants seront prochainement publiés au
jo savait jusqu'à présent seuls les
officiers et les agents de police
judiciaire certains personnels du
ministère les représentants assermentés
de la fld étaient habilités par
l'article du code du sport à s'attaquer
au trafic de produits dopants donc ce
décret renforcera cette coopération
interministérielle dans ce domaine il
est indispensable il instituera
également une instance nationale de
lutte contre le trafic des substances ou
méthodes dopantes organise qui aura donc
cette vocation de mobiliser plus
efficacement de façon coordonnée
l'ensemble des acteurs permettra
également cette instance nationale de
conjuguer les efforts et les ressources
du ministère de la fld de la police
nationale de la gendarmerie des douanes
de la direction de la concurrence de la
consommation et de la répression des
fraudes et de l'office central pour la
répression du trafic illicite des
stupéfiants
la direction générale de la santé l'
agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé et
le service central des courses et des
jeux ainsi que la mildt dans chaque
région nous aurons donc ces commissions
régionales de lutte qui seront cette
déclinaison des instances nationales
un dernier point concerne l'industrie
pharmaceutique 12 novembre dernier à
paris
conjointement donc avec la main avec
unesco avec le conseil de l'europe
ministère des sports a organisé cette
réunion des acteurs du mouvement sportif
et des organisations représentatives de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
ainsi donc que certaines firmes lors de
cet événement les bases d'un processus
relatifs à la collaboration
pharmaceutiques ont été présentés et
donc les firmes présentes ont été
invitées et nous avançons à s'inscrire
dans cette démarche pour qu' il y ait ce
travail en amont absolument
indispensable avant que ces molécules
puissent être mises
sur le marché voir éventuellement
détournés de leur usage
un défi compliqué y a pas de fatalité
nous devons continuer à le relever et ça
change
sachez que pour moi il est essentiel
dispensable de pouvoir profiter de
pouvoir bénéficier de l'ensemble du
travail que vous avez conduit dans le
cadre de cette commission denquête pour
que ce défi à la fois politique du sport
et pour la santé des sportifs nous
puissions le faire évoluer
collectivement dans notre pays et dans
un contexte international qui est
évidemment prégnant merci beaucoup pour
ce moment de propos sans doute un peu
long liminaire il n'était pas l' oms il
était très complet ça nous évitera de
poser un certain nombre de questions
puisqu'il a été très précis je voudrais
vous poser une première question qui
aurait pu être la dernière mais comme on
a quasiment fait le tour de l'ensemble
du problème parce que vous avez été
d'une précision absolue
est-ce qu'on va avoir au parlement
français a semblé salle sénat comme
d'habitude la possibilité de se pencher
sur un texte à l'automne par exemple ou
un peu plus tard sur le sport d'une
manière générale et on pourrait à ce
moment-là revenir sur les problèmes de
dopage et on pourrait essayer d'utiliser
ici au sénat les informations que nous
avons glanées au fil des auditions
c'était à la fin je voulais vous poser
cette question mais devant le plat qu'on
paie tu aurais dit quelqu'un
d'autres exposés je vous en remercie ça
a été très intéressant mais le nombre de
questions pour vous ce qui me concerne
c'est la seule que je voulais vous poser
nous demanderons suite à notre dynamique
rapporteur il devra sans doute encore et
puis les collègues qui sont là pour eux
aussi intervenir s'ils le souhaitent
donc ma question de débuts sur la
question de faim s'il est bien sûr le
demande donc aux rapporteurs de prendre
le micro de poser de nombreuses
questions dit il encore donc c'est à moi
mais c'est le président madame la
ministre merci d'avoir contribué à notre
commission d' enquête parlementaire et à
l'évidence d'avoir suivi ces travaux
parce que nous avons donc le sentiment
que vous avez suivi ça avec beaucoup de
d'attention et j'espère beaucoup
d'intérêt en tout cas le sénat a pris
l'initiative de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire avec le clair
d'accroître l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le dopage et il est vrai que nous
avons depuis depuis trois mois
maintenant pratiquement
jour pour jour depuis le 14 mars dernier
nous avons beaucoup positionner nous
sommes même allés à la rencontre de tout
un ensemble des instances
internationales comme le cio l'uefa la
fifa de l' agence mondiale antidopage du
sehy lui cela des laboratoires de
recherche etc afin d'avoir une vision la
plus complète et la plus juste de cette
problématique du dopage et je pense que
nous serons nous avons bien sûr encore
quelques quelques ajustements opérés
nous serons autour du 18 juillet en
capacité de publier ce rapport de notre
de notre commission en tout cas notre
ambition c'est vraiment de je suis
intimement convaincu que c'est une
ambition partagée de promouvoir une
vision humaniste du sport et cette
vision humaniste elle passe justement
par la lutte contre tout un ensemble de
déviance tout un ensemble de tricherie
dont le dopage fait partie et je crois
effectivement que nous sommes efforcés
de nous emparer de toutes les dimensions
que vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure que
ce soit la dimension de santé publique
la dimension éthique les dimensions
juridiques policière même répressive
sans oublier bien sûr la dimension
économique médiatique à travers à la
fois des approches locales nationales ou
internationales
je crois et c'est cela sans doute
l'aspect gratifiant l'aspect positif de
notre travail que nous serons vraiment
dans quelques mois dans quelques
semaines en capacité de de vous faire un
certain nombre de propositions qui je
l'espère attireront votre votre
attention à vous mais également à
l'ensemble des acteurs du mouvement
sportif concerné par par ce sujet en
tout cas nous nous sommes fait je dirais
une raison en termes de constat à savoir
que tous les sports était touché par par
le dopage même si certains étaient plus
exposées que d'autres que tous les pays
étaient également concernés même si nous
ne sommes plus dans une situation de
dopage d'état de dopage
institutionnalisée comme on a pu le
connaître il ya quelques décennies dans
dans certains pays
mais nous sommes également aujourd'hui
que la conviction que le dopage concerne
également le sport amateur et pas
simplement le sport professionnel ou le
sport de haut niveau voire même le sport
loisir
voilà et puis nous avons également je
crois qu'ils la certitude avec les
collègues sous la houlette de notre
président qu'en matière de lutte
antidopage il ne fallait surtout pas
baisser la garde
bien au contraire et qu'il fallait sans
doute cultiver préserver peut-être même
consolider encore un savoir-faire
spécifiquement français très souvent
d'ailleurs reconnu or dehors de nos
frontières
puis je termine à ce tout petit mot
introductif en disant c'est avec vous
que l'on achève notre notre série
d'entretiens avec vous et puis avec le
président de l'agencé mondiale
antidopage john fahey
je voulais également au nom de notre
notre groupe de notre commission vous
remercier pour votre coopération pour
votre collaboration je pense en
particulier à la mise à disposition de
tout un ensemble de documents que vous
nous avez transmis et je dois également
félicité vos services pour la rapidité
pour l'efficacité avec lesquels vos
services se sont mis un autre à notre
disposition
et puis également pour vous remercier
pour la reconnaissance de notre travail
puisque je sais que dans certaines
circonstances vous avez eu l'occasion de
mentionner de citer le travail d'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
notamment lors du colloque organisé par
le cnosf sur cette problématique du
dopage
effectivement j'avais aussi mentionné la
même préoccupation que le président
c'est à dire la confirmation que bientôt
il y aurait cette loi cadre sur la
modernisation du sport et si oui si elle
intégrerait ou pas la problématique du
dopage avant d'être parlementaire avant
d'être ministre
vous avez été notamment médecins
l'équipe de france de volley ball et je
dois donc tout simplement vous demander
si vous avez été confronté à usage de
produits dopants à travers en
particulier 7 7 d'ici
line et si et si oui si vous en avez
tiré des enseignements qui vous inspire
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
question c'est le rapporteur qui veut
qu'on fasse comme ça donc qu'est-ce que
vous souhaitez monsieur le président au
mot je m'adapte j'ai pratiqué le judo la
wallace ou wii question après question
qu'ils soient pas question très bien
vous souhaitez que je réponde à la fin
la voûte par contre n'en fait les
communes avec celles du rapporteur du
coup sûr sur le calendrier de la loi
d'avoir merci d'avoir le ministre je me
permettrai pas de vous dire qu'au fur ça
vous fait quoi
très bien d'abord merci de vos propos
par rapport à ma maison
effectivement je veux dire quand votre
commission d'enquêté a été mise en place
j'ai immédiatement souhaité que dire
l'ensemble des archives des documents à
disposition qui existait à la direction
des sports vous soit communiquée et donc
cette très clairement j'avais dit le
directeur du sport tout ce qu'on vous
demande donné le et donc je les fais
bien volontiers il me semble que c'est
est indispensable d'avoir à venir cette
transparence
au moment où génère de votre votre
commission denquête je n'ai jamais été
confrontée comme médecin équipe de
france de volley ball féminine à dire
une quelconque interrogations par
rapport au dopage
je lai était plutôt dans mes
interrogations sur l'exercice de mon
travail de médecins dans le cadre des
équipes de basket professionnel
quentin dire des basketteurs arrive des
états unis ils n'ont pas forcément les
mêmes c'est à dire les mêmes codes
d'emblée sur la lutte contre le dopage
que nous et il faut assez vite leur
réapprendre
quelles sont nos règles propres de lutte
contre le dopage
et donc mes inquiétudes non plus étaient
visés
i au moment où un des basketteurs
américains arrivés dans l'équipe dont
j'étais le médecin de leur faire
découvrir les règles de notre pays
vis-à-vis de la lutte contre le dopage
mais ce seul moment où j'ai pu être
confrontés selon peut dire à dans
l'exercice de ma profession à cette
lutte contre le dopage continue absolue
pourtant oui une question madame la
ministre concernant l'efficacité des
contrôles et d'ailleurs ça rejoint un
petit peu ce que vous évoquez
on est en rappelant le contenu du
rapport de dick pound la réalité du
dopage semble-t-il n'est pas du tout ce
qui correspond aux résultats de ces
contrôles de ces tests puisque
finalement on arrive toujours quasiment
au même résultat
c'est à dire des tests positifs dans 1 2
% des cas est-ce que vous avez sentiment
que la réalité du dopage va bien au delà
de cette de cette réalité chiffrée
concernant les tests positifs
il ya ce débat sur l'efficacité des
contrôles qui à l'évidence ne se traite
pas au nombre de contrôles réalisés
j'ai un échange il n'y a pas si
longtemps avec président de fédération
internationale de cyclisme il mais on
fait beaucoup plus de contrôles que tous
les autres donc il n'y a pas de problème
puisqu'ils sont effectivement tous
négatifs ou presque tous négatifs
la quantité n'est pas forcément le bon
critère pour l'efficacité de la lutte je
pense qu'on est tous persuadés du coup
il y a néanmoins la fois une attention
je pense à avoir sur les contrôles qui
sont effectuées dans des parcours de
construction du haut niveau et qui font
partie pour un jeune de la règle que
l'on apprend tôt et hank qu'il y ait
dans nos structures de formation des
sensibilisations et contrit des
contrôles antidopage ou cherche rien
mais on cherche à montrer qu'il y a
aussi une politique éducative et le
contrôle à sa place à cette occasion
par contre quand on est dans une
recherche anr dépistage de quelqu'un qui
a triché qui est une autre porte
d'entrée et notre vision du contrôle
anti-dopage clair que tout ce qui
concerne aujourd'hui le passeport
biologique sont des éléments qui sont
indispensables des preuves non halal
itic tout ce qui concerne aujourd'hui la
multiplication des contrôles inopinés
les périodes de contrôler la
localisation des sportifs pouvoir
bénéficier donc de leurs paramètres
biologiques pour mieux cibler les
contrôles pouvoir être plus pertinent a
évoqué le cannabis tout ça à dire
conduit à ce que nous soyons plus
pertinent plus pertinent aussi il faut
se le dire c'est l' équilibre à trouver
entre l'organisateur et celui les
contrôler ce que nous évoquions être
juge et partie sans enlever la
responsabilité au mouvement sportif
le mouvement sportif
coupe impliqués et donc le mouvement
sportif et pas question de le désengager
une contre le dopage sans que on a
besoin par contre d'avoir une
organisation comme celle qui va être
celle sur le tour de france cette année
où il est très clair que l'organisateur
n'est pas celui qui organise les
contrôles qui cible les contrôles à
l'ensemble des éléments
donc c'est tout cet environnement qui
nous permettra d'améliorer l'efficacité
du contrôle
mais j'insiste sans se dire un que le
chiffre c'est la réponse à tout mais
sans se dire qu'il faut se désengager
aussi d'un aspect ou contrôle peut avoir
cette vision un peu préventive
combien par le contrôle on a aussi
dissuadé ensuite un certain nombre de
deux jeunes ou d'autres d'y tomber tout
à l'heure nous vous avez évoqué le
travail de votre de votre ministère on a
eu parfois dans nos auditions le le
sentiment que y avait quand même un
travail qui restait à faire en matière
de coordination de transversalité de
coopération interministérielle que ce
soit avec mr de la santé des affaires
sociales que ce soit avec l'intérieur la
justice et affaires européennes voire
même peut-être avec le ministère de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et de la
consommation est ce que vous n'avez pas
le sentiment que la situation peut être
sensiblement améliorée
à l'évidence oui à l'évidence oui j'ai
évoqué la mise en place d'une instance
nationale de coordination est créé qui
est en préparation sur le sujet les
instances de coordination sur chacun des
territoires
à l'évidence nous avons besoin de mieux
articuler tous les acteurs de la chaîne
et nous essaierons dès cette année à la
fois donc sur le plan réglementaire avec
ce décret qui sortira est à la fois sûr
le tour cet été d'avoir une meilleure
coordination entre les différents
acteurs qui luttent donc pour à
l'éthique du sport et contre le dopage
merci stéphane mazars puis jean claude
carle
oui madame me stresse vous avez rappelé
que la lutte contre le dopage donc en
france était d'abord donc un problème de
santé publique
et vous avez d'ailleurs déclaré votre
attachement à cette lecture là cette
grille de lecture là vous avez
clairement indiqué que pour vous il
fallait pas pénaliser l'usal de produits
dopants mais quand même quand on vous
écoute
il y avait là des termes concernant donc
l' usage de produits dopants qui font
qu'ils font référence à ce volet pénal
et est à ce domaine pénal je vous citez
vous épargne récidivistes ou de parler
de tricheurs de trafiquants dont comment
bien quand on est aussi parfois un
certain niveau de dopage avec des
systèmes organisés et que derrière
effectivement
le dopage il y as au delà du fait qu'on
veut gagner des gains de notoriété et
dans certaines disciplines sportives à
un certain niveau des gains financiers
très importants
je vous ai joué bien entendu sur votre
position menoua le cas de nos auditions
on a eu des retours de deux sortes de
sportifs qui eux sont assez clairs sur
le fait que si on pénalise l'usagé de
produits dopants
il y aura un effet dissuasif qui sera
assez fort et qui pourra être une
barrière une limite à la ligne qu'il ne
faut pas franchir
donc qu est ce qu on leur répond et puis
il ya également des services d' enquête
ils sont pratiquement tous unanimes pour
dire que si demain on pénalise l'usagé
de produits dopants
c'est leur permettra à eux service
enquêtes d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans
leurs investigations d'avoir des moyens
supplémentaires pour
mais pour lutter contre le dopage
notamment pour remonter des filières
parce qu on sait qu'aujourd'hui il ya
véritablement des filières organisées
derrière donc la pratique la pratique
dopante
donc qu'est ce qu'on leur dit également
eu voilà donc moi c'est un petit peu les
réflexions sur lesquels donc je voudrais
qu'on qu'on revienne étant précisé que
ce qui nous est souvent brandie et à
juste titre et c'est vrai que c'est ce
sont des sportifs qui déjà vont être
impactés physiquement par l' usage de
produits dopants et on connaît pas
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui qu'elles seront
réellement ses impacts et puis ils sont
déjà largement sanctionné dans le cadre
sportif et on sait que pour un sportif
qui se voit donc suspendre de toute
activité pendant deux ans et peut-être
demain quatre ans c'est déjà très lourd
et on va pas envoyé derrière les
barreaux des sportifs
bon il ya quand même principe en droit
pénal qui est celui de la
personnalisation de la sanction qui fait
que bien évidemment le sportif qui pour
la première fois serait confondu pour un
usage de produits dopants
il serait pas renvoyé derrière les
barreaux par contre lorsqu'on parle de
récidivistes qui en toute connaissance
de cause ont gagné beaucoup d'argent et
beaucoup de notoriété par l' usage de
produits dopants l'a peut-être se pose
la question de savoir s'il faut pas
aller plus loin sur la sanction est
notamment débordé sur sur le plan pénal
donc voilà c'est vrai que moi je pense
que si aujourd'hui tout en gardant la
philosophie qui est la nôtre et qui est
vertueuse qu'il faut à tout prix mettre
en avant celle d'un problème de santé
publique et de protéger avant tout la
santé du sportif
aujourd'hui le sport a pris une telle
place dans la société en matière de
notoriété et en matière de d'argent
qu'il faut peut-être avoir une autre une
autre grille de lecture des mots là
c'est moi je vous soumet ses réflexions
et encore une fois que dire à ceux qui
nous disent on veut plus de moyens
d'investigation mais et la pénalisation
est en moyenne
et que dire à ceux qui nous disent
aujourd'hui moins sportif de haut niveau
je peux vous assurer que ce serait
dissuasif
si une sanction pénale était la clé
lalo ministre sujet qui n'est pas facile
j'ai même vu que des expressions
président de l' agence française de
lutte contre le dopage croit ici dans
votre commission denquête dit qu'il
était également opposée la pénalisation
et puis dans une autre expression qu'il
était pour je pense que ce débat il
n'est pas facile à il n'est pas facile à
trancher
on a une approche aujourd'hui qui est
une approche effectivement santé éthique
c'est c'est le rôle l'enduit du
ministère des sports
c'est le rôle aujourd'hui de promouvoir
le sport comme comme outil de santé
publique
cette nuit là la première des choses qui
est notre mission publique elle est
celle là et est ce que c'est à nous
d'être derrière la pénalisation d'un
sportif derrière la wii il ya des
filières derrière c'est vrai mais il ya
aussi des lois pénales qui permettent à
l'air d'aller rechercher ce trafic
j'aurais envie qu'on puisse trouver les
dispositifs pour lever l'omerta sur
l'ensemble des acteurs qui ont été par
certains réseaux mafieux ou par un
environnement particulièrement prégnant
on le voit dans la ferme sont en jeu
hier combien de gens ont souffert au
tour 1 qu'on puisse se donner les moyens
de permettre à ce que des sportifs
puissent s'exprimer sans encourir des
sanctions pour faire progresser la lutte
entre le dopage et du coup faire
progresser la lutte contre ces
trafiquants ça serait notre rôle que
d'être sur le registre pénale pour
l'usager mais sur le débat n'est pas
facile merci jean claude carle puis
dominique bailly merci monsieur le
président le ministre nous avons visité
le laboratoire de châtenay malabry
laboratoire qui était
à la pointe de la recherche en matière
de lutte contre le dopage ou détection
plutôt des produits dopants et notamment
de deux le p o mais c'était p&o elle a
elle aussi évolué puisque nous en sommes
je crois à la 4 quatrième génération et
est ce que aujourd'hui ce laboratoire
qui est acquis à mon sens ce toujours un
laboratoire de référence et pathé passer
par d'autres laboratoires que ça chez
ludo than que ça soit celui de cologne
et il nous semble travers la visite
qu'on a fait qu'il souffre un peu de
moyens en équipements un des équipements
qui certes sont assez onéreux ce sont
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'euros
et est-ce qu'il serait pas justement
dans le cadre de la mobilisation de tous
les acteurs dont vous avez parlé je
pense en particulier aux industries
pharmaceutiques de trouver des
partenariats et innovant pour permettre
justement à ce laboratoire de disposer
de moyens que ça ne repose pas sur le
seul financement le seul financement
public et j'en viens ma deuxième
question ce laboratoire a été rattachée
donc la flds qu'un adossement à une
universités notamment l'université
spécialisé dans la pharmacologie
ne serait ce pas aussi quelque chose à
envisager
en tout ce qu'on peut pas imaginer que
tous les laboratoires de bon niveau
comme laboratoire français puissent est
pertinent sur aujourd'hui toutes les
mollets belle volée culty sorte on va
c'est sans doute le laboratoire de
cologne qui travaillent aujourd'hui
soleil car qu'est à nouvelles molécules
semble-t-il enveloppe et c'est bien
qu'ils aient un laboratoire comme ça a
été bien qu'à un moment donné le
laboratoire de châtenay soit en pointe
sur la cera et sur le pays donc il me
semble que sur les molécules où on a
besoin en l'air d'avoir beaucoup de de
recherche qu'on puisse partager est un
élément un élément indispensable venir
les savoir-faire des uns et des autres
sur le laboratoire et son positionnement
ce qui est indispensable c'est de lui
laisser toute l'indépendance sur la
fonctionnalité sur les techniques
ça c'est absolument indispensable
finalement la seule chose qui le
rattache le dire ces financements qui
sont aujourd'hui
finalement les mines et les financements
du ministère des sports
cette indépendance
il faut être attentif à ce qu'elles ne
soient pas remises en cause par an tu l
financement qui vient des deviendrait
d'autres partis c'est au sein d'une
autorité administrative indépendante
avec des financements publics
on voit combien même les le débat que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure sur l' agence
mondiale antidopage
les fédérations internationales disent
on paye c'est notre prestataire de
services et les gouvernements disent
nous on veut que ça soit une instance de
régulation et de contrôle international
c'est pas la même approche
donc on voit bien que la la réalité du
positionnement du laboratoire
aujourd'hui selon moi ne lui permet pas
de de travailler suffisamment sur la
dimension recherche
jospeh d'investissement on voit bien il
a un fond de roulement tous les ans qui
lui permet tout même d'investir dans du
matériel et de suivre l'évolution du
code mondial antidopage compte la
dimension la dimension recherche enduit
est insuffisante insuffisante
il y en a dans la loi avant tout au sein
du laboratoire au sein de la fld un tout
petit peu dans les antennes régionales
mais ne le font pas du tout donc sur ce
registre
alors est ce que par rapport à cette
dimension recherche qui aujourd'hui
mériterait d'être plus importante
la bonne solution ou la solution serait
de s'adosser de sortir le laboratoire et
de l'ado c'est une université un labo de
recherche haute pharmaco c'est une
perspective qui franchement mérite
d'être regardée mais avec ce souci des
financements et d'indépendance qui est
vraiment indispensable si on veut
continuer à avoir une quelconque enfin
une pertinence sur sur les contrôles
vont faire parce que le laboratoire
s'est avant tout aujourd'hui les
contrôles et la pertinence des contrôles
l'efficacité des contrôles etc
merci dominique bailly oui madame la
ministre je voudrais revenir sur le
volet prévention
beaucoup de personnes auditionnées nous
ont fait part bien évidemment que la
prévention était un outil essentiel pour
lutter contre le chômage vous l'avez
aussi évoqué le tournage contre contre
la lutte sur à tous ces sénateurs jeu
ce lapsus parce que je sors d'une
réunion sur le chômage des jeunes en
europe où l'on se doit
ont présenté un rapport donc je vous
présente mes excuses mais donc pour
lutter contre le dopage mais mao au fil
de ses auditions
j'ai eu le sentiment que certaines
fédérations étaient plus ou moins
impliqués dans cette prévention et moi
je voudrais avoir votre appréciation
et comment pourrions-nous évaluer
justement cet engagement des fédérations
dans cette lutte contre le dopage est de
mettre en place vraiment une prévention
forte
alors bien sûr il y à la charte
d'éthique qui doit être déclinée par
chaque fédération on en est où et et je
pense que là il ya matière à améliorer
le dispositif
donc voilà sur la prévention j'ai
peut-être vous faire sourire
tu ne te dire qu'on a dans notre pays un
un lien permanent aux médicaments si le
médicament qui peut tout c'est compris
la mi temps d'un match de football de
d'un plateau de débutants
on va avoir parfois éducateurs et qui
ont donné un sucre ça n'a rien à voir
avec le dopage mais sait on ce n'est la
deuxième mi temps il faut qu'il y ait
quelque chose pour faire la deuxième mi
temps et c'est quelquefois je vais
encore vous faire sourire mais à la mère
de famille autre qui va donner une
vitamine c pour aller à l'école ça
valait mieux pour apprendre à travailler
alors on est tout même dans une dans un
environnement collectif tout ça autour
du médicament qui peut tout compris des
as pour pas vieillir et autres donc on a
des ressources
cet environnement qui est aujourd'hui
extrêmement prégnant dans notre dans
notre pays et j'ai évoqué le travail
fait avec
à la fois avec les enveloppes
territoriale du cnds et donc les clubs
sportifs sensibilisation gère des
projets des appels à projets pour les
clubs pour accompagner les clubs d'en
finir 7
cette approche c'est à dire du sport et
cette prévention autour de cette
éducation au sport et de l'autre enfin
pas de l'autre côté mais au niveau des
conventions d'objectifs avec les
fédérations nous avons éditeurs qu'on
n'avait pas rogner sur les moyens sur
l'exercice 2013
donc il ya avec chaque fédération ni un
programme de sensibilisation de
prévention de formation
les éducateurs sportifs dans les brevets
professionnels dans les bébés tous ont
une sensibilisation une formation it
antidopage
donc on essaie d'être extrêmement
présents sur sur cette cette prévention
là les fédérations le les fédérations
aujourd'hui n'ont pas toutes la même
n'ont pas toutes la même en train de
dire à travailler sur la prévention la
sensibilisation à la lutte contre le
dopage serait mentir de dire le
contraire
et là encore c'est pas parce qu'on fait
x contrôle qu' on est présent sur ce
champ donc sensibilisation c'est le
dispositif quand elle est en place avec
la mildt avec le cs ans et le dispositif
des clubs c'est la convention
d'objectifs avec les fédérations
évidemment quand elles n'ont pas de plan
en donne pas de sous c'est aussi simple
que ça mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
fédérations qui ont moins besoin
d'argent public que d'autres il ya donc
c'est un sujet important la charte
éthique doit trouver sa place dans le
texte global indispensable des grands
enjeux du sport dans la loi de
modernisation du sport c'est en tous les
cas dans ce cadre là qu'elle trouve a
toute sa place
si jean pierre chauveau oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
plusieurs venaient de donner plusieurs
réponses à des questions qui est
maintenant je souhaitais poser mais je
pense qu'au niveau de la prévention
c'est vraiment au niveau et y compris
est déjà au niveau scolaire au niveau
bien sûr de toutes les écoles du sport
je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
d'indispensable il faut probablement que
l'accent soit mis là dessus en parallèle
le moi je souhaitais savoir puisque
autrement vous avez des responsabilités
au niveau de l'europe
est ce que par rapport aux différents
ministères des sports sur l'or sur
l'europe telle qu on la définit
aujourd'hui est également au niveau des
fédérations est ce qu'il n'ya pas des
liens plus forts à avoir encore de
manière à ce que tout le monde travaille
vraiment dans le même sens et avec 1,1
point de vue une idée finale qui est
vraiment de d'abolir au maximum tout ce
qui peut toucher le dopage
vous pouvez parler aussi du laboratoire
mais je pense que les laboratoires ont
aussi mais vous l'avez dit intérêt à
travailler ensemble que certains axes de
recherche dans certains domaines
d'autres dans d'autres mais de manière
être encore plus efficaces ou un de
manière est vraiment répondre au souhait
de nous tous coupe
pratique du sport à l'école dispensable
et aujourd'hui moi je me réjouis que cas
de réforme de l'école et de la formation
des enseignants du premier degré est un
mythe cette formation de nos enseignants
à la pratique sportive
c'est indispensable que l'on apprenne
dès le premier degré et la place me dire
de bien se sentir dans son corps c'est
un élément indispensable
vous aurez aussi cadre de la réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur un maître venir
à être attentif sur les amendements qui
sont en ce sens pour qu' il y ait cette
place aussi l'activité sportif chez nos
étudiants
on a aujourd'hui une situation en
matière de santé tout simplement qui
s'est dégradée avec de moins en moins
d'activités sportives de moins en moins
de place qui était sportive la première
des préventions l élan et l'élan il ya
en europe un travail au sein du du
conseil du conseil européen avec
aujourd'hui une instance qui reste
l'instance internationale et unesco et
yama à dire que les gros acteurs ennuis
sont son plus haut niveau simplement de
l'europe autant sur les paris truqués
autre sujet des tic
la première étape qui est une étape
d'avoir un texte européen et une
adhésion européenne à cette lutte contre
les paris truqués est une étape qu'on
n'a pas encore franchi autant sur le
plan de la lutte antidopage
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans une
dimension des quand même plus de 170
pays 173 quand j'ai dit tout à l'heure
je ne sais plus qui ont signé la
convention internationale de l'unesco
qui donc est la base le socle pour
derrière adopté le code mondial
antidopage avec néanmoins des
difficultés qu'on voit les pays
d'afrique qui ont signé cette convention
enfin il ya 2 il ya deux laboratoires
aujourd'hui en afrique donc
nous on peut travailler sur le plan
européen entre nos laboratoires
c'est un mets un moment donné la réalité
la réalité d'un certain nombre de
territoires fait qu'ils n'ont pas de
laboratoire pertinent fonds qu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens d'avoir l'abattoir il
faut qu'il faut déplacer les palerme en
faut et c'est donc là l'ajustement
internationale est indispensable si on
veut pouvoir emmener tout le monde n'est
pas se retrouver dans un dispositif où
on n'aurait pas des poches de résistance
mais mais des poches où il ya à
l'évidence pas les moyens d'être au
niveau d'une lutte qu'on souhaite tout
savoir
puis il ya le les fédérations
internationales qui je le dis vraiment
le débat qui va sortir sur le rapport de
dick pound est un débat extrêmement
important sur le positionnement du
mouvement sportif par rapport par
rapport au gouvernement et enduits quand
je dis que la fédération internationale
souhaite que l' agence mondiale
antidopage soit avant tout avant tout je
veux dire leur prestataire de service je
pense que travis taggart lui est sur une
position de dire il faudrait que dire
l'agent ce mondial soit financée
uniquement par les gouvernements soient
totalement indépendante des fédérations
internationales
preyat en jeu il ya un enjeu qui n'est
pas négligeable financier évidemment
donc il ya cet équilibre pas facile à
trouver entre il faut continuer on
n'arrivera pas si on n'est pas avec le
mouvement sportif
on n'y arrivera pas si on le fait pas
avec eux et en même temps il faut qu'on
trouve le bon équilibre pour que
personne ne se retrouve dans une
situation d'être juge et partie et du
coup d'avoir une lutte antidopage et
inefficace merci
c'est une question qui s'adressera plus
aux médecins qu'aux ministres même si le
ministre est médecin
quel regard jetez-vous sur
l'accompagnement médical de la porte de
la performance sportive et estimez vous
que le suivi médical réglementaire des
sportifs de haut niveau soit appliquée
avec la même rigueur selon les
fédérations
c'est un peu gênant la ministre je crois
qu'on a fait énormément énormément de
progrès dans la préparation de nos
sportifs de haut niveau dans la
coopération dans l'ensemble des outils
d'accompagnement que nous avons vers la
performance et et sans utiliser de
produits dopants et bien on a énormément
progressé sur cette approche et il est
indispensable que le rapport de la cour
des comptes dit il c'est peut-être le
pivot opérationnelle du sport de haut
niveau français mission qui a été donnée
au nouveau directeur général de l'insep
est vraiment de pouvoir être ce pôle
ressources
ce pôle ressource qui permettra à tous
les directeurs techniques nationaux à
tous les entraîneurs nationaux à tous
les médecins qui accompagnent des pôles
sur le territoire d'avoir une vraie
ressource partagée autour de
l'excellence de la performance un joli
conte à l'insep par exemple d un
environnement médical paramédical qui
est qui est en jeu ne sais combien de
divisions au dessus de ce qu'il était il
y à il y a quelques années
cela ne veut pas dire que dans le suivi
médical donc de l'ensemble de nos
sportifs on en fasse parfois même
quelquefois pas trop en train de
regarder surveillance peligal
réglementaires dans les pôles espoirs
on a parfois tendance à avoir multiplié
le nombre alors pas du tout varié de
recherche de contrôle antidopage mais
des preuves d'efforts qui se multiplient
de regard de celui qui est parfois
presque excessif par rapport à un vers
le besoin médical qu'on a à dire de
d'avoir toutes ces données chez un jeune
sportif qui vient d'intégrer un pôle
espoir
je trouve qu'on a aujourd'hui un des
chantiers qu'on ouvre sans doute
la bonne proportionnalité de ce qu'on
n'impose à tous jeunes sportifs de haut
niveau qui est parfois du même niveau
que ceux qui préparent les jeux
olympiques de rio
donc il ya cette proportionnalité qui
n'a pas été trouvé avec parfois aussi
garde un des éléments du certificat
médical d'aptitude qui on le voit dans
certaines pratiques sans risque a pu
être un handicap à la pratique pour le
plus grand nombre
et côté de ça on est toujours bien sûr
toujours des drames des morts subites
sur les terrains de sport donc tous est
cet équilibre entre un dépistage pas un
électrocardiogramme au moins une fois un
suivi médical excessif parfois parfois
dans des pôles l'excellence pour ceux
qui préparent les jeux olympiques et un
certificat médical d'aptitude pour faire
du sport en scolaire qui est un handicap
pour certains quartiers pour accéder
tout simplement une pratique sportive
on a aujourd'hui un proportionnalité si
le terme est correct mais un lire la
surveillance médicale de l'aptitude
jusqu aux sportifs de haut niveau et à
faire bénéficier les meilleurs de
l'ensemble de l'environnement qui leur
permettra d'aller jusqu'au plus haut
niveau de performance
la loi avant de rendre la parole aux
rapporteurs qui a sans doute encore
quelque chose à vous demander
on arrive vers la fin de l'audition je
vous rassure
ah si vous voulez rester on peut
continuer mais pouvez-vous nous dire
quelles sont les mesures prises
rapidement ce pas un inventaire précis
les mesures vous avez pu prendre depuis
que vous avez commencé aux fonctions de
ministre en matière de lutte contre le
dopage et c'est mesure où la lutte
contre le dopage la mise en oeuvre des
mesures pour lutter contre le dopage
sont les mesures que était facile à
mettre en oeuvre
avez-vous rencontré des résistances
est ce que vous avez eu des dépressions
autres grimm si c'était le cas de quelle
nature est ces résistances
dans mon introduction et c'est d'avoir
j'ai essayé de montrer qu'on avait pris
comme mesure avec donc la fois la
dimension sensibilisation pour le pour
le plus grand nombre à la fois la
dimension
oui le tour le tour 2013 pas obtenu
comme ça n'a pas obtenu comme ça c'est à
dire que il ya un moment donné une
expression publique pour exprimer des
accords sur un dire la façon dont les
contrôles antidopage donc pouvait être
organisée par une instance qui était
juge et partie qu'on ne tirait pas
suffisamment profit de l' enquête faite
par l'usada
sur la fère us postal et coup il m'a
semblé important qu'on puisse sur ce
registre poussé poussé les barrières
pour obtenir cette convention il ya une
convention donc évidemment avec une
autorité administrative indépendante
avait fait le dr son indépendance mais
nous avons dans l'environnement à dire
médiatique unique exprimé notre souhait
est que dès le tour de france 2013 nous
puissions avoir ce ce résultat et même
si les pressions pour dépression mais je
vous mentirais en vous disant que tu as
eue au téléphone
2 c'est un président du président de
l'union cycliste internationale me
disant qu'il faisait beaucoup de
contrôler que il savait ce que c'était
que l'hématocrite et qu' il n'y avait
pas de raison mais ça c'était un premier
coup de téléphone
et puis ensuite nous avons progressé
progresser ensemble et nous avons pu
aboutir à ce qu'il me semble être
aujourd'hui une étape intéressante et
qui sera intéressante pour deux
autre organisation et pas seulement dans
le vélo se rapporte rio va falloir que
nous accélérions un peu nous avons
accéléré et bien évidemment comme d'un
mot la conclusion oui madame la ministre
je reviens sur le sur le volet
prévention parce que nous avons reçues
en particulier le délégué où ils délégué
national d'ee des antennes médicales de
prévention du dopage lors je sais que la
situation est très inégale d'une région
à l'autre d'un territoire à l'autre et
donc il nous a fait part d'une situation
préoccupante concernant ses antennes
régionales il ya même des territoires où
ces antennes ont disparu pour moi et
simplement
et donc ils sont inquiets pour leur
avenir leur situation financière
degré de motivation qui serait en train
de s'émousser
est ce que la question de
d'un financement à travers non pas la
part territoriale du cnds met de la part
nationale est une question ouverte
aujourd'hui le sujet les antennes une
calme eric complètement d'être
aujourd'hui évalué et j'ai une
inspection générale sur ce sujet j'ai
une inspection générale sur ce sujet sur
le bilan des antennes médicales pour
pouvoir y lire prendre toutes les
mesures qui nous permettront de voir où
est ce que le juste financement ouais ce
qu'est la pertinence de leur rôle
il ya énormément vous voulez de
l'indiquer c'est tout à fait exact
d'inégalités sur le territoire sur sur
ses antennes et je vous ai donné les
chiffres des personnes qui les
consultent en moyenne sur le territoire
national ça reste extrêmement faible
donc on a sur ce registre à l'évidence
besoin de mieux évaluer ce qu'il ya
quand même si même si c'est dire qu'à
passer enfin il ya quand même 580 1000
euros sur un an qui sont mobilisés sur
sûr c est sur ces antennes donc on a je
crois que le rôle indispensable alors
après les financer avec la part
nationale du cnds est monsieur le
sénateur combien j'ai c'est de sauver
cet établissement publics et
établissements publics qui avaient donc
engagé deux fois son budget un plan de
redressement qui nous emmène jusqu'à
2016 qui a conduit à des -30% sur la
part nationale -30% sur la part
nationale qui a conduit et c'est très
pénalisant pour tous les territoires
français à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
conseil d'administration du cnds à la
fin de l'année 2013 et celui de 2012
pardon et celui qui s'est déroulé en
mars dernier j'ai pu attribuer moins de
20 millions d'euros alors qu'il y avait
un milliard cinq de projets en phase de
cette demande
donc nous sommes à redéfinir
et à travailler sur l'exercice 2013 pour
qu'au 1er janvier 2014 ils ont pu re
définir les critères d'intervention du
cnds force de dire qu'on peut être
partout on est finalement nulle part et
on est l'état n'est plus suffisamment
brad deviez puis surtout l'établissement
était dans une situation où son fonds de
roulement et aider cette année négatif
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué la
continuité de l'action gouvernementale
en matière de lutte antidopage
par-delà donc les alternances chaude et
savoir s'il ya une continuité sur la
prise de position de notre pays
concernant la la double liste des
produits dopants parce que c'est vrai
que la france a toujours été contre
l'utilisation de deux types de
substances une pendant la période de
compétition l'autre pendant la période
d'entraînement
est ce que vous êtes toujours sur cette
position
la réponse est oui fermement oui je jure
sur cette position parce que c'est très
intéressant et remercie ministre moore
consacré le temps qu'elle a comme ça que
je vais à présent mais il faut aussi
vous donner la parole pour conclure
cette rencontre si vous le voulez bien
aucune obligation si vous êtes en
conclure on arrête là s'ils voulaient
conclure vous pouvez le faire bien sûr
je vais conclure peut-être monsieur le
président avec votre question initiale
donc travaillent effectivement à un
texte de loi de modernisation du sport
je pense que ça ne serait pas
satisfaisant qu'on passe par quelques
modifications pour y glisser quelques
génère article sur le dopage uniquement
aujourd'hui on a modifié 22 fois
successivement le texte initial la loi
sur le sport et son socle dire la loi de
84 on n'a pas arrêté depuis on avait 90
articles 1 370 aujourd'hui et on n'a pas
arrêté de faire un peu avec fois un peu
d'éthique une fois un peu de paris une
fois un peu d'âge en fait c'est il me
semble que le temps est venu
mais il me faut un peu de temps pour
qu'il y ait effectivement une grande loi
d'orientation de modernisation du sport
qui reprennent l'ensemble de ce que sont
aujourd'hui les enjeux du sport dans
notre pays la relation entre le sport et
l'argent l'éthique la relation
aujourd'hui entre l'état et le mouvement
sportif
les équipements sportifs il y a notre
registre de l'euro 2016
des interrogations qui n'ont jamais été
aussi importantes de la commission
européenne sur l'intervention publique
dans des équipements qui servent ensuite
à des sociétés commerciales
il y a donc des enjeux à de nombreux
niveaux
oui des tic il y a donc dedans il y aura
bien sûr le dopage
on sait qu'on a besoin d'eux
de progresser sur notre législation sur
les paris une législation qui avait été
prise un peu un peu rapidement avant le
mondial 2010
on a aussi des acteurs nouveaux par
rapport à la loi de 84 de la place des
collectivités locales est extrêmement
importante aujourd'hui premier financeur
public du sport
ils sont pas assez d'ailleurs autour de
la table dans les moments de décision on
le voit sur conférence du cnds ou bien
il n'y a pas de poids suffisamment pour
les élus locaux or c'est eux qui
connaissent le mieux je me dis alors
leurs territoires les uns critères
d'intervention donc les enjeux sont
importants en jeu pour moi de santé
publique qui me semble essentielle qui
n'est aujourd'hui pas suffisamment dans
la loi alors que le sport peut être un
bel outil de santé publique
il sera content on sort moment sur le
dopage qui plutôt tendance à la détruire
mais on a voilà il ya ya ya aujourd'hui
deux de multiples enjeux en termes de la
place du sport dans notre société sont
un outil économique un outil d'emploi un
outil d'emplois et donc il me semble que
cela nécessite un travail qui je
l'espère aboutira pour un dépôt en
conseil des ministres avant la fin de
l'année pour pouvoir être débattu au
parlement en 2014
merci de tout ce que vous avez dit si
vous avez terrier merci pour ces
conclusions en particulier en réponse à
une question j'avais posé mais qu'il
était aussi relayée immédiatement par le
rapporteur donc
on y retrouvera les siens nous allons
suivre attentivement pour ce qui nous
concerne est un membre de la commission
de la culture de la casse est à nous et
pour vous le savez bien du suivi des
dossiers sportifs
donc même avec cette commission denquête
qui s'achève demain au niveau des
auditions nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir dans les mois à venir sur le
dossier du sport d'une manière générale
et six nouveaux textes il ya nous le
regarderons avec beaucoup d'intérêt
merci à la main merci beaucoup
voilà pour l'audition de valérie
fourniront la ministre des sports elle
était entendue par la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur l'efficacité de
la lutte contre le dopage
si vous souhaitez revoir cette audition
est là disponibles en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr bonne fin de
journée à tous